you think there's more  demonic activity today or we just are  more  aware of it  i would say and this has been my  experience over the last 17 years it's  not that the devil has upped his game  but that more people today seem to be  willing to play the devil's game  what's the devil's game  to get people to reject god  an inch from christ is victory that's  his game  just non-believers correct specifically  in christ  yeah i think there's a lot of people you  know you look at a lot of satanic groups  some of them they're very various levels  i think some that are on the superficial  level don't really worship satan but  their goal would be to remove god  from the conversation you see that  played out where  maybe some government groups get  together and they have some type of  opening prayer  and then satanic groups will want the  the right to come in and be able to  offer some prayer as well